c'est un tourbillon absolument
incroyable j'ai un peu de mal à y croire
ça va mieux qu'hier enfin ça va mieux ça
allait très bien hier oui je commence un
peu à réaliser aujourd'hui quand
j'entends le cononcours 2023 j'ai plus
le moment de me dire qui c'est en fait
oui mais j'ai encore ce moment où tout à
l'heure je je parlais d'un concours que
je lu il y a longtemps et je réalisais
que ça y est je moi j'avais le même prix
c'est c'est un sentiment c'est c'est
très dur à décrire c'est dommage pour un
écrivain mais ça serait l'occasion
d'écrire un livre sur cette émotion
toute particulière au moment de de ce
prix vous avez dit avoir accompli un
rêve de gosse qu'est-ce que vous pensez
que se disait Jean-Baptiste Andrea 9 10
ans quand il dit ok qu'est-ce que je
veux faire de ma vie oh je voudrais être
écrivain est-ce qu'il visait est-ce
qu'il imaginait pouvoir un jour
décrocher une récompense comme celle-ci
non mais j'ai jamais révé de décrocher
le goncours ou quelque récompense que ce
soit moi je rêv non mais je oui sûrement
je rêvais d'être écrivain depuis 2016
j'ai quitté le cinéma où j'avais bossé
pendant 20 ans pour devenir écrivain
pour me consacrer au mots à la
littérature et et là depuis 2016 je me
réveille tous les matins avec cette
sentiment de léger sentiment d'irréalité
de me dire je suis vraiment en train de
vivre mon rêve là le goncours c'est
encore quelque chose qui était qui qui
qui est hors de ma sphère de conscience
et qui est venu se rajouter à cette
expérience et qui la rend encore plus
incroyable et c'est un roman que vous
avez immédiatement dédié à votre
éditrice qui nous a tristement quitté
cette année elle a cru en vous au tout
début est-ce que ce sont des moments
comme ça des rencontre clé qui change un
parcours notamment dans la vie d'un
écrivain c'est une des rares personnes
de ma vie et qui qui a été une passeuse
et qui m'a dit je te vois je comprends
ce que tu écris je je j'ai reçu ce matin
une vidéo de d'elle et de moi notre
première présentation du livre au au au
représentant de mon éditeur et la fin de
la vidéo c'est elle qui dit je viens de
la reg regarder parce que et et elle dit
on va faire de ce livre un feu
d'artifice euh sur donc c'est le premier
roman et voilà elle m'a elle m'a elle
m'a elle elle a elle voyait comme moi
peu l'impression moi j'ai toujours
l'impression que l'envers c'était
l'endroit et et elle c'était pareil elle
avait des rêves elle avait des visions
folles et et voilà on a partagé ça et
drô vraiment vraiment et cette année
c'est pour vous le concour alors que
vous n'étiez pas forcément le candidat
idéal je le dis avec toute la
bienveillance possible cel la fait 7 ans
seulement pardon que vous vous consacrez
à l'écriture de roman avant c'était le
cinéma qu'est-ce que cette carrière dans
le cinéma a apporté à votre manière de
concevoir l'écriture je pense pas du
tout au cinéma quand j'écris maintenant
littérature mais c'est vrai que 20 ans
de cinéma c'est une école d'exigence
très très très très intense c'est très
rigoureux le cinéma on a 1h3 ou 2h pour
pour distraire pour toucher pour
bouleverser ça ça ça ça ça développe
après 20 ans de travail quotidien
peut-être une perception de de de ce
qu'est le
rythme la meilleure manière de générer
une émotion sans pour autant sombrer
dans le cliché comment aller chercher
l'originalité sans pour autant que ce
soit l'originalité pour elle-même donc
tout ça ça s'est affiné pendant 20 ans
de cinéma donc je je je pense que je
dois beaucoup à cette école mais après
20 ans j'ai eu besoin de liberté et pour
moi et je l'ai trouvé dans la
littérature absolument on dit parfois
dans dans certaines pièces de théâtre et
de certains metteurs en scène qu'ils ont
cette capacité à nous faire vivre une
pièce de théâtre comme un film est-ce
que c'est ce que vous essayez de faire
dans vos romans ou ou pas du tout je me
pose pas du tout la question en fait je
pense pas qu'il y ait de différence
entre le film Le et même et le livre
mais même jeall dire la musique et la
peinture ce sont des des Art des formes
d'art quand il nous quand ell nous
émeuvent qui génèent des images des
émotions et qui nous font voyager d'une
manière ou d'une autre qu'on soit plongé
dans un livre ou qu'on soit debout
devant un un tableau ou devant un
orchestre donc je je pense pas
particulièrement au cinéma voire pas du
tout quand j'écris mais on est une
culture d'image donc les mots provoquent
beaucoup plus d'images de nos jours
qu'il n'en provoquaiit probablement il y
a 200 ans ou en tout cas il fallait plus
de mots il y a 200 ans pour générer les
mêmes images dans les esprits d'
lectrices et d'é lecteurs en tout cas
vous réussissez très bien à nous faire
voyager on revient à ce roman lumineux
veiller sur elle une histoire d'amour
impossible est-ce que ce ce côté
histoire d'amour impossible compliqué
pleine d'obstacles c'est ce qui rend
aussi ce rent extrêmement consistant
c'est ce qui lui donne de la force oui
alors j'ai envie de dire très banalement
que l'amour fait quand même tourner le
monde après c'est pas du tout une
romance he c'est une on emploie là le
mot amour au sens le plus large du terme
dans son acception la plus vaste
c'est-à-dire une relation extraordinaire
entre deux qui voilà qui parfois s'aime
tellement qu'il se déteste et ça c'est
important parce que c'est c'est la la
relation évolue et change et se
transforme tout au cours du mais c'est
effectivement la pile nucléaire de ce
Romin pour moi alors je dis impossible
puisque tous les opposes on a MIMO d'un
côté qui est un sculpteur extrêmement
talentueux mais extrêmement pauvre j'ai
envie de dire presque maltraité par la
vie de l'autre côté Viola une jeune
héritière extrêmement complexe
richissime qui fait preuve d'une
intelligence remarquable c'est un
personnage central dans ce roman qui que
vous avez construit comme éminemment
complexe oui c'est pour elle que je
voulais écrire ce roman en fait voilà
vier sur elle Viola est un mélange de
diverses femmes que j'ai rencontré qui
m'ont porté dans dans ma vie la dernière
étant mon éditrice des femmes très
fortes des femmes visionnaires et c'est
vrai que c'est c'est déjà difficile
quand on a une vision c'est difficile
quand on est intelligent c'est difficile
quand on veut sortir des chemins que la
société nous offre comme étant tout
tracé en N disant la sécurité est là le
danger est là mais si on a avait envie
d'explorer entre entre les deux et c'est
encore plus difficile quand on est une
femme et en plus quand on est une femme
à cette époque là donc ça c'était
incroyablement romanesque et je voulais
rendre voilà de créer cette figure d'une
héroïne puissante et fascinante qui se
battrait contre le monde entier et
contre elle-même parfois la question
c'est ça peut-on s'extraire de de ce
qu'on est de son destin de ce qui est
prévu pour nous je je pense qu'on peut
s'extraire de ce qui est prévu pour nous
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
s'extraire de nos propres limites et des
des des verrou qu'on s'impose c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de les briser C
et c'est toute la complexité autour de
ce personnage de Viola ils sont pris
dans leur histoire d'amour mais aussi
dans l'Histoire avec un grand hache
celle de l'Italie du 20e siècle et bien
sûr de de ce contexte particulier de la
montée du fascisme oui absol que vous
arrivez très bien à nous faire vivre
merci alors c'est un des seuls sujets de
mes études qui me plaisaent c'était
l'histoire du vouszit sur Paris on
précise et et ça je me rappelle bien de
ça ça me fascinait l'étude des
totalitarismes c'est une étude de la
folie humaine donc c'est c'est c'est
évidemment la folie est romanesque et en
fait comme le roman parle évidemment de
tyranie comme je disais tyranie qui est
faite à cette héroïne elle trouvait
cette tyranie intime un miroir naturel
dans la grande tyrannie politique qui
est en fait porté exactement par les
mêmes personnes par les mêmes hommes et
je dis homm en le gen rant et et voilà
ce sont les mêmes hommes qui sont
motivés par la même peur et par la même
lâcheté qui qui vont faire ces de types
de tyrannie dans le cadre de l'intime et
dans à l'échelle de la
Grand ex très naturellement c'est c'est
cette petite histoire s insérée dans la
grande très naturellement on vient de
parler de cadre politique et un cadre
géographique également très important
pour vous puisque l'Italie vous ne
l'avez pas choisi au hasard c'est un
pays auquel vous êtes très attaché par
vos origines et puis aussi parce qu'il
vous a donné un certain rapport à la
beauté au sublime à l'art oui je crois
que quand je suis allé en Italie pour
mon premier pays étranger où j'allais à
15 ans je suis passé du stade
d'adolescent mec basique comme on l'est
beaucoup à cet âge-là qui avait une
vision utilitaire du monde à tout d'un
coup découvrir la beauté il y a quelque
chose d'autre et pour ce gamin qui cet
ado qui voulait devenir écrivain contre
V et mararé d'arriver dans ce pays où
l'art est dans la rue ou des ou ou parce
que vous passez par Florence ce qui n ce
qui n'est pas rien en terme de d'
et je me dis là-bas à fl en fait des
gens ont consacré leur vie à l'art ça
n'est donc pas anormal alors que tout le
monde a l'air de me dire que c'est pas
vraiment un métier je crois qu'il y a ça
qui s'est passé dans ma tête de manière
assez inconsciente probablement et qui
va définir une partie de votre carrière
bien sûr à ce moment-là l'art que vous
mettez à l'honneur avec Mimo donc ce
sculpteur chargé de confectionner c'est
pas rien cette piétage j'ai envie de
dire qu' a dans ce rom beaucoup de
spiritualité il y a un côté lyrique oui
moi je suis quelqu'un de très spirituel
alors je l'inverse j'ai aussi des un
rapport très compliqué à tout ce qui est
religieux et notamment les dogmes et la
construction politique de la religion
spiritualité est spirititualité là voilà
moi je crois je crois que le devoir du
romancier est de rendre visible
l'invisible quel que soit l'invisible
c'est mon c'est mon c'est mon rôle de de
donner à voir quelque chose qu'on ne
voit pas au quotidien c'est comme ça que
je que j'envisage un roman est-ce que
c'est ce qui a fonctionné aussi bien
j'ai envie de dire ce mélange entre de
la spiritualité bien dosé ce côté très
important et cette mise à l'honneur de
de ce l'Art avec un grand A cette
histoire d'amour ce contexte historique
est-ce que on avait tous les ingrédients
pour un roman aussi fascinant que
celui-ci je ne sais pas du tout ce qui
fonctionne et si je le savais je serais
déjà en train de réécrire un autre roman
qui fonctionne pour moi c'est quelque
chose de très instinctif ça un jour une
histoire s'impose à moi et je me dis
waouh comment je vais raconter cette
histoire je ne sais pas comment je fais
au sens où chaque fois que je finis un
roman je je me dis mais comment je vais
recommencer je ne sais pas et à chaque
fois on reparle bien sûr d'une page
blanche on dit votre écriture qu'elle
est étincelante je trouve qu'il n'y a
rien de plus vrai j'ai j'ai écouté un
éditorialiste qui disait très justement
que parfois quand on parcourt un roman
on tourne les pages et puis bon on
parcourt cette histoire on peut la
trouver fantastique on revenait à chaque
page précédente pour relire les mots que
vous aviez choisi c'est ce qui m'est
arrivé hier en lisant votre roman
j'avais envie de ne pas louper un seul
mot et ça c'est quand l'écriture est
particulièrement au rendez-vous mais ça
me touche beaucoup parce que je
recherche une forme de sobriété dans
l'écriture et d'aller chercher le
c'est r aussi dans les personnes qui
sont récens mais dans cette forme qui
donne l'impression d'être le plus simple
possible en fait et qui à qui veut
l'entendre laisse justement percevoir
des résonances assez intenses j'espère
en tout cas moi je les entends et c'est
très important pour moi dans une forme
dite traditionnelle de de de d'aller
chercher cette petite résonance très
très pure je vous le confirme ça génère
beaucoup d'émotions ce roman veilleer
sur elle qu'est-ce que ça va changer
pour vous second cours bah tout votre
vie c'est c'est non j'ai j'ai déjà
beaucoup de tourné j'ai j'ai j'ai la
chance d'être porté depuis le début par
des libraires donc j'ai accepté et par
une maison d'édition l'icô au clast et
j'ai accepté cette année énormément
d'invitations donc en fait je pense que
ça va étendre ça mais au fond bah c'est
toujours moi c'est toujours le même
livre donc je pense que voilà je sais
pas ça va changer grand ch merci pour
votre simplicité votre générosité et
puis pour ce roman magnifique veillez
sur elle c'est le nouveau concours de
Jean-Baptiste Andrea merci infiniment
pour cette interview et puis bon courage
pour les suivantes